seit 1969 pflegt das österreichische
bundesheer partnerschaften zu
bedeutenden österreichischen
wirtschaftsbetrieben sowie zur
öffentlichen gebietskörperschaften
städten und gemeinden
diese kooperationen sollen die beziehung
zwischen her und bevölkerung weiter
vertiefen und die akzeptanz der
militärischen landesverteidigung erhöhen
eine verbindung sehen zwischen dem
militär und der gesellschaft
gegenseitiges verständnis erzählen das
ist gerade in zeiten mit diesem sehr
wichtig 1979 wurde die vierzehnte
partnerschaft zwischen der garde und der
industriellenvereinigung eingegangen
wir leben diese partnerschaft sehr
intensiv wir haben gemeinsame werte wir
lernen voneinander und wir profitieren
voneinander
wir glauben dass das auch ein beitrag
ist für die sicherheit österreichs ist
es ein bekenntnis zum bundesheer und zur
sicherheit
aus diesem anlass gibt es einen festakt
dessen höhepunkt die aufführung des
großen österreichischen zapfenstreichs
ist
[Musik]